We start our problem by multiplying by the reciprocal of our second fraction. We
flip it over. We can factor this first numerator as 5x plus 3 times 5x minus 3,
since this is the difference of two perfect squares. Our denominator is also a
difference of two perfect squares. So we have 2x plus 3 times 2x minus 3. For
this fraction, we can factor this numerator by finding the factors of negative
18 that sum to negative 7. Those factors are negative 9 and positive 2. We use
factoring by grouping to get 3x plus 1 times 2x minus 3 for this first
numerator. And finally, for this denominator we find factors of positive 45 that
sum to negative 14. Those two factors are negative 9 and negative 5. These
factors let us rewrite our middle term, and then we can use factoring by
grouping. We get a denominator of 5x minus 3 times 3x minus 1. Now that we have
all of our factors, let's cancel factors that simplify to 1. These two factors
would reduce to 1, and these two factors would also reduce to 1, leaving us with
these factors for our answer. You're doing amazing at dividing rational
expressions and factoring if you got this one correct.